should I give up or keep trying to find
my dream business this is a real
question I came in from one of my
readers Valeria of Valeria Valyria how
are you pronounce it apologize
she wrote a long email a long email like
telling her life story scroll Scroll
scroll and and basically the summary is
she's 23 years old think she wants to
start a business started up on one path
going into property development went
along that route realized it wasn't for
her so then she got into design user
user experience got into that and then
realized it wasn't for her she wasn't
passionate about it and she's worried
that she's gonna be bouncing around from
one job to another job to another job
until she's 45 I never realized what she
wants to do in her life and she's
worried cuz she's an ambitious person
she wants to go in the chief and she
wants my advice and what to do this is
really common this is something that a
lot of people go through and when you're
young when you're trying to figure out
what you want to do it's so important to
try new things and it's okay to bounce
um one thing to another thing to another
thing the key here is that each time
you're doing it you're following a
passion and that passion might grow and
might bloom into something amazing or
might do indle and when you get in there
you realize how that wasn't what I
wanted to do because look at the the
alternative that's when you go and you
start on one path you think you're gonna
love it and you continue on you continue
on and you realize that you hate it and
now you're stuck in a career that you
can't get out of that's a lot of people
most people don't wake up super excited
and charge to go to their job they're
stuck because they didn't have the
courage to try different things and the
younger you are is 22 years old it's a
great opportunity you're still very
young now's the chance and don't think
of it as a failure to bounce um one
thing to another thing and spend three
months here and 6 months there and may
not look good on the resume but it's
it's great for you on your life resume
because you're learning about yourself
and you're figuring out what it is
exactly that you want to do and a lot of
the world's most successful
entrepreneurs did that too they
bounced around in the early years bounce
from one thing to another and never
being quite sure what they wanted to do
until they found something that they
could stick with and run with I remember
when when I started my business when I
was in university I thought it's gonna
be a banker I never wanted to be an
entrepreneur I didn't have aspirations
to be an entrepreneur I thought it'd be
a bank run in my high school yearbook I
wrote were gonna be in ten years are
gonna be a VP at some Bank that's what I
thought I was gonna do and I realized in
university that maybe this banking thing
isn't for me and I went on some job
interviews and and realized you know
what I don't think I can do this I got
to try something else
so thought about consulting consulting
looked good it looked interesting it
look like I could solve lots of
different problems with some fun
companies and started down that path
that okay this is my path forget Bank
I'm gonna consult it and same thing I
started into it and I did some
interviews with companies and it just
didn't seem like it would be the right
thing and I kind of worried like I don't
know I thought I was gonna do banking my
whole you know high school career I was
aiming to be a banker and that wasn't it
and now consulting wasn't it what what
am I gonna do what's it what's the path
for me and I came across an opportunity
to hook up with two friends and start
this biotechnology software company and
when I did it I didn't think this is the
be-all and end-all I'm gonna be a
biotechnology software guy for the rest
of my life but I hooked onto the
opportunity and I liked it and my
mindset at the time was I'm gonna spend
a year on this on this one a year it's
risky it's doing my own thing it's no
steady paycheck the company had nothing
coming in I'm gonna take a year and try
because the worst-case scenario I'm back
to where I am right now and I still
don't have any responsibilities any real
responsibilities that I wasn't married I
didn't have any kids you know as now's
the time to go out and do it so I spent
the year and I never came back I never
came back to wanting to go get a job I'm
so grateful that I took that leap and so
if you're not sure what to do yet just
follow your heart because it's gonna
lead you towards a place that eventually
you'll get on the right path and it's
knowing that you're on the right path
you have to have the confidence and
believe that even though the path is
murky
and may not even exist you know the path
you're following may not have been
created yet you're forging a new path
and even if you only see darkness and
confusion around you you have to trust
that the path you're on is the right one
it serves you and there is light at the
end of the tunnel I reminded of the
story of Steve Jobs when he was in
university and dropped out because it
just wasn't for him the courses he was
taking were not interesting to him and
this was supposed to be his ticket his
ticket to the big time he's taken to
making money get a nice secure job
that's what everybody tells you and he
dropped out to hang out with computer
geeks at their computer clubs and the
drop in on courses that talked about
fonts and typography and people said
you're crazy like what are you doing
this is nuts why are you doing this you
had you had your path all lined up for
you then you're hanging out with
computer guys who's gonna need a
computer why are you taking classes
about fonts and letters it's because it
interested him he was following his
passion and he had no idea what he was
doing he didn't have a huge plan to say
this is gonna be Apple and it's gonna be
a huge company he had no idea he was
just listening to his heart and he ended
up creating one of the first personal
computers and it had great fonts and it
was the only computer that cared about
style and fonts and how the letters
looked and that separated them from
everybody else
and he's able to build a hugely
successful company and it's easy to say
and look back oh well that's how he did
it but when he was there he had no idea
he was scared he didn't know this was
gonna work out he didn't oh he's gonna
be an entrepreneur he just knew that the
path he was on going to university and
taking those classes wasn't for him so
we switched up to something else and
that's the attitude you need to take if
you feel like you are not on the right
path you need to stop what you're doing
and go on a different path one that
serves you better and there's more
following your heart this is really
really difficult for ambitious people
because if you're really ambitious you
want to achieve you want to see results
you want to feel like you're doing
something and when you're in this murky
area you're not getting any results and
you feel like you're just fail
and feeling and feeling it's really
difficult because you have high
expectations and sometimes when you
create these lofty expectations you set
yourself up for failure another quick
example from my background I've invested
into a salsa dancing company ok it's one
of the largest in North America we teach
five to six thousand people a year how
to dance salsa and when I was looking at
this business I joined as a student okay
I wasn't an investor right from the
start I was a student I signed up to do
salsa I had a lot of things working
against me
I'm really tall so I'm taller than most
people who are in this also seen that
means I take big steps ok I'd never
understood salsa music I don't speak
Spanish I didn't learn the language a
lot of people learn they growing up and
Here I am like as an adult trying to
pick it up so there's a lot of things
going against me if I had thought I'm
gonna get into this as a business it
would have never worked because there
were too many factors against me but I
did it because I loved it I took it out
of curiosity and I explored that
curiosity and I fell in love with it I
fell in love with salsa dancing I became
a DJ an instructor an investor it became
a real business opportunity for me
because I followed my heart even though
logically it didn't make any sense from
the start and that's what you have to do
you have to trust that your heart is
right and will eventually guide you on
the right path because it will you have
to believe that and have the courage to
throw something away that isn't the
right way for you to go even though you
may have put dollars time effort energy
you've committed to other people you've
told people you're going down this way
it takes a lot of guts and a lot of
courage to throw all out away and say
now I'm going here
but if you want to have a great life if
you want to not be one of the 90% of
people wake up and drive to a job that
they hate everyday then you have to
create that path for yourself and
believe that it's gonna work out believe
Phyllis Lee watching like the video give
it a thumbs up below makes you want to
do more and please leave a comment let
me know what you think let me know how
you found your path if you have a
question about your business leave it
below I make a video response thank you
so much and I'll see you soon